In this section, we will primarily work in Unreal Engine to create a metahuman from a face scan.
As we work through this exercise, you will note that this is broken down into a step-by-step process that is found in your slide deck.
As we complete portions of the practical exercise, I will review the completed steps.
So, let's jump into Unreal Engine and begin creating a metahuman.
With Unreal Engine open, as mentioned at the beginning of the course,
the RealityScanFaceScanAsset has already been imported and is located under the Assets folder in the folder named ScanMesh.
If you wish to go through all of the steps I will show,
you can locate the original OBJ file and textures that have been provided in the Source Files folder named 11301 RealityScanAsset.
Now, I'm going to navigate to our Course Topics folder
and in here, I'm going to create a new folder to work in by pressing Ctrl Shift N.
I will name this EX for example and then open this up.
Inside of here, we will get started by importing the 3D mesh.
Start by going to the import over here,
then inside of the Source Files folder named 11301 RealityScanAsset,
in the RealityScan folder, select the FaceScanMesh and the textures and then select Open.
The Import Content option will appear and if you are working with an asset that has separate meshes,
for instance the eyes and the head are separate, go to Static Meshes and enable Combine Static Meshes.
Then go here and select Import.
Once the asset and textures are imported, open up the FaceMesh to inspect it.
Make sure it is facing the X-axis.
If it is not, you can re-import it and make the appropriate adjustments to the offset rotation in the import options.
The next step is to prepare the mesh.
Now, let's create a new material in order to apply the textures to our 3D head mesh.
Right click in the Content Browser and select Material.
I will name this M underscore RC for RealityCapture and then open this up.
Going back to the main viewport, I will undock the material so that I can add the textures to the material graph.
And from here, I will select the Albedo and Normal map and drag these into the material graph.
You don't necessarily need the Normal map but since we have it, let's use it.
Inside of this material, I will connect the Albedo to the Base Color and then connect the Normal map to the Normal.
You may find it helpful to adjust the specular in the event your material is a bit shiny.
So I will press 1 to create a constant and set the value to something like 0.3 and then I will connect this to the specular.
I will save this and go back to our main viewport.
With the new material selected, let's go to our Static Mesh window
and apply this to our 3D head mesh by assigning it over here.
Now, before we move on, let's review some of the steps we just completed.
For the Mesh to MetaHuman workflow, begin by importing the 3D head mesh and textures.
If working with a 3D model that has separate meshes, in the Static Mesh section of the import options, check on Combine Meshes.
Once imported, check to see that it is facing the X-axis, otherwise adjust the rotation offset in the import options and re-import it.
One note is that the import options will look different from previous versions of Unreal Engine 5.
The next step is to prepare the mesh.
Apply a material using an albedo texture.
It is helpful to use an albedo map in order to separate the sclera from the skin tone.
With the material results, the 3D face model should have the eyes open with a visible seam separation of the eyelid and eye to assist with the tracking marker placement.
The mouth should be closed and the face should have a relaxed neutral pose.
Something to note is that if the model does not have eyeballs, the empty sockets may generate artifacts in the mesh fitting.
Now, let's jump back into Unreal Engine and continue with the next steps.
The next step of this workflow is to create a metahuman identity asset.
There is an existing one you can inspect located in the course topics folder inside of the folder named Mesh to Metahuman Identity in the folder named Sample Metahuman ID.
This is already gone through the process of being generated using the 3D headscan data.
Let's go back to the Mesh to Metahuman Identity folder and create a new folder to work in by pressing Ctrl Shift N and name this EX for example.
Inside of here, right click in the content browser and select Metahuman Animator and then select Metahuman Identity.
The name you give this will be the name that will appear in the Metahuman Creator later on.
I will name this RC underscore scan.
Now, I will double click to open it.
I'm going to dock it up here and once this window opens, you may be prompted with an Epic Games sign in.
The next step is to populate the Metahuman Identity asset.
Go to the main toolbar, go to create components and drop this down, select from Mesh
and then search for the 3D mesh.
I will type in RC underscore scan and then scroll down to locate it.
Once it is selected, it may take a moment for it to load.
Once loaded, navigate to the front of the face scan.
In the top left panel, select the body component.
Right below, select the body type that you wish for this Metahuman to have.
In my case, I want to select the female medium normal body weight.
Now, before we move on, let's review the steps we just completed.
After importing and preparing the face scan model, the next step is to create a Metahuman Identity asset.
Right click in an empty space in the content browser, select Metahuman Animator and then Metahuman Identity.
The name you choose will be a placeholder for it in the Metahuman Creator.
Once you open up the Metahuman Identity asset, you may be prompted to sign in with your Epic Games account.
Inside of the Metahuman Identity asset window, the next step is to populate it with the 3D model and assign a body type.
Go to the main toolbar, go to create components and drop it down.
Select from mesh and then search for it.
It will take a moment to load in the viewport.
Next, select the body component and then select the body type you want your Metahuman to have.
Now, that's it for this section.
In the next video, we continue our hands-on exercise with the next steps of the Mesh to Metahuman workflow.